to say i can speak now to jurgen
tordenheifer who's a german journalist
and actually leads his own political
party to this form now that's team todd
and her for the justice party uh really
good to have you on appreciate
your time jurgen first of all the
withdrawal of u.s forces from
afghanistan
did they abandon the people of the
country there or not in your opinion
it's
a big mess it's a catastrophe for the
american prestige and
they have lost everything they have lost
control over the situation
they are out of the game now
they were going to be the u.s damned if
they stayed probably lots of critics for
them being there in the first place
damned if they they left i mean it was a
difficult decision but did they make the
wrong one
to leave was not
wrong
i i think they had to leave the country
like all the countries who have
conquered afghanistan
during the hundreds of
years during the past had to leave
afghanistan
but the the question is how you leave
they said we will leave on a certain day
so the taliban started to wait
they had the time they knew that the
americans would leave this was extremely
stupid this was by the way trump
and but nobody forced
obliged
biden to continue this strategy
and there was a possibility to say
we ask you
a certain rights
women rights
certain rights
certain human rights
to guarantee the security of those who
have been working with us with the
americans or and their allies
they didn't get these
guarantees they could have said
we will stay here
until you give these clear guarantees
and they just said yeah we are going to
leave
and now they can back the taliban
taliban have the control
and now we have to negotiate with the
taliban
and we have lost the control over the
situation and the united states are
are ridiculous
they have lost their prestige
and
i think it's very hard for the americans
because
their imperialism is very to be the
number one in the world is very
important for them
but who will want to be an ally of the
americans if they know
what will happen
if you are an ally
of the americans if you are a thousand
vietnamese or
or an afghan
now everybody knows what will happen
kisenza once
has said
it's dangerous to be an enemy
of the united states
but it's
fatal
badly
to be a friend of the united states
and
kabul afghanistan has shown that again
afghanistan has proven itself to be
notoriously difficult to try and take
control of and to tame for the u.s to
try and turn it into a western-style
democracy was that something that was
doomed from the beginning
i think
it was not very difficult for the
taliban
to win this war i have predicted this in
many tv shows
since the beginning of this war
i started 20 years ago i wrote books
about that
only afghans can beat
defeat afghans so they they had no
chance and they made a big mistake
this coalition
they created they made a coalition with
warlords
with criminals like
doston hegmatia
and
they made a coalition with corrupt
people
so the government the system was
completely unpopular and this is one of
the reasons
why the population
of kabul and and condos and other cities
led the taliban in
the government was unpopular
they wanted to get rid of
corrupt regime
the american have presented to them
and by the way
the situation
in afghanistan was not very good
less than
half of the population has access
to clean water
more than 50 of the people
are poor have almost nothing to eat
so the situation is very bad in this
country
it's
some people say it's worse
than in 2001.
so how's that possible
there was nothing to lose how's that
possible the u.s and its allies have
spent two decades there they pumped
trillions of dollars in
how is it possible the situation can be
so bad has it been has it been slipping
through the cracks into corruption i
mean what is the legacy going to be of
that 20 years
you know i i not only i don't talk only
i've been in afghanistan so often
they have
the afghans have paid for
for ridiculous things incredible sums
clear
corruption
and if you put the money in the into the
pockets
of the warlords
i've seen yesterday on on cnn
the house of dustin
is one of the most criminal warlords of
afghanistan that's a guy who put the
taliban after the victory over the
taliban in 2001
into containers and put them
into the desert and let them die i've
seen his house
i've never seen such a luxurious house
this house has been constructed with
hundreds of millions
stolen
from the people of afghanistan and paid
by the people of the united states
so and the second thing is
the americans
did not invest in people
they invested
in
in military
in military strength in military
strength of the afghan forces but if you
don't have
moral strength if you don't have values
you defend if you have corrupt
killing people corrupt i i repeated
warlords the most horrible
warlords you can imagine i'm normally
i'm quite
nice with afghans it's it's i don't like
to talk about warlords but we have some
warlords there
and these were the best partners of the
united states and one of the reasons why
the people of afghanistan didn't want to
defend their cities against the taliban
and why it was so easy to enter and the
americans had no i they just don't know
afghanistan they had no idea how it
worked they don't know
how the taliban attack a city the
taliban attack a city
by infiltrating this city weeks before
with their people
and then they have hundreds or thousands
of people in this city
waiting
for the attackers
and then it's very difficult to defend a
city
if the enemy has already
his people in this city so they have no
idea
and they were not interested
to know the people when i went to
afghanistan
i went to the market
not with bodyguards
not with a car
a special car
just by walking and i was invited to
drink tea
by everybody
i couldn't drink all the tea but people
have been incredibly nice and i had the
opportunity to talk to these people
to talk about the good things the bad
things the things they like
from from our side the things they did
didn't like
when american politicians or german
politicians went there
they went there with special cars and
bodyguards
and they said we have seen now the war
they haven't seen anything
they've seen palaces
they have met politicians they never met
the population and you have to meet the
population and and we had
you're again i do apologize i'm afraid
i'm going to have to interrupt you there
um she's just running out of time really
appreciate
your thoughts and the stories you're
telling us there though i guess jurgen
tordenhofer leader of germany's team
toddenhoffer the justice party thank you